deke thanks so much for coming on the
show thanks for having me appreciate it
super excited for the convo
be a lot of fun talking about cls
sustainable
talking about homedow
yeah yep glad to be here getting the
whole planet just onboarded with
next-gen energy technologies yeah
it's a no-brainer
and it's great because there's
already epic developers like you guys
like cls sustainable
that have been doing it
and that have been onboarding and have
been
um
making people happy uh commercial and
industrial especially um
and even residential yep
uh
with their new technology so making
people happy with those new tech
so
and keeping earth
just in a nice
healthy sustainable regenerative style
of prosperity instead of one that um
is short-term thinking this now we're
long-term thinking which is great yeah
so this is the second episode of home
dial podcast which i'm super excited
about yeah yeah
first one was with andy
and
it's cool because gce also and uh
guaranteed clean energy and cls
um have had an ongoing partnership now
for quite some time
and like
uh
in just serving the transition to clean
energy technologies and so now cls is
also coming on board as a dev of home
dow too
as that
is beginning to roar and take off
so i would love to read the bio of deke
to give you guys a little bit of a
better understanding of
how exactly he has been building
holistic energy systems and how he's
continuing to do so
so he's co-founder and ceo of cls
sustainable a commercial industrial and
community solar developer and epc
engine procurement and construction cls
provides a holistic approach to achieve
renewable energy goals for people and
organizations they serve including early
stage development engineering
procurement construction project finance
operations and
maintenance deak was named entrepreneur
of the year for the energy industry by
the american business awards in 2019 and
2021. yes sir
that's an awesome goal
it's so cool yeah
such a cool award
nice and you guys can find the links in
the buy below cls sustainable.com also
deak's linkedin profile is down there as
well as all the home dial links
deek let's jump into things by
understanding like your journey through
energy itself
so um
this this is actually my 20th year in
the energy industry so i started uh back
in 2002 2003 in the oil and gas industry
so kind of a complete opposite of where
i am today right
it was more on the finance and uh where
i was working with a small independent
operator here in dallas texas uh we were
drilling for natural gas wells which at
the time were right on top of right now
which is the barnett shale
at the time it was the largest natural
gas
field that was discovered
nobody knew how to really tap into it
though because it was a tight shell
formation
and in
2003 2004 a gentleman by the name of
george mitchell with mitchell energy he
he had there's always been frack
technologies but he had come out with a
slick water frack where they used a ton
of sand and used it as a propent to hold
open
the layers of the shale to then release
the hydrocarbons right
at that point in time devon energy came
in
acquired mental energy and then a bunch
of your larger independents and at that
time made a bunch of these
uh oil and gas firms like your
chesapeake energies your devon energies
eog resources they all moved into these
shale plays
and
where they're they're naturally rich in
hydrocarbons whether it be oil and or
natural gas
this one specifically was natural gas
but what my job was is we would actually
raise capital to go out and drill wells
uh in the barn and shale and i did that
for about three or four years um and at
the time um again with all these large
organizations moving in uh the company i
was with actually got acquired
so it was either make that transition or
kind of go out on my own and i've always
had an entrepreneurial spirit so
i said you know what what the heck i'll
give it a shot and i had opened up my
first oil and gas company in in 2007.
we had acquired some acreage in another
shale play which was emerging at the
time called the fayetteville shale in
arkansas and we did some drilling out
there uh and again uh with with frack
technologies back then and
back then you didn't
nobody really understood uh
the the negative effects of what
fracking was actually doing right um i'm
sure you've seen it on tv shows or
even in movies right the matt damon
movie where people actually had
fire coming out of their their water
faucets right that their gas coming out
of their water faucets that they could
then light and fire up
so
you know seeing that kind of detriment
at this point i was i was probably in my
my late or mid to late 20s and it it
kind of had blinders on right you you
knew stuff was happening but it wasn't
one of those things that was really at
the forefront of your mind it was just
how can we exploit the hydrocarbons how
can we pull them out right
so
i did that for a couple of years on my
own um we were dealing with an operator
that was out in arkansas who ended up
actually taking um some of our capital
investment that we had we had injected
into them and and took off uh
fortunately for us we actually acquired
the leases beforehand so i was able to
take the leases over and by default i
became an operator myself and so
an operator is just uh
kind of more of a in a construction term
with someone who's overall operating the
well drilling the well
organizing everything and i don't have
really a i didn't have at the time a
geological background right uh so we
just hired the right types of people and
we ended up drilling and operating our
own wells for several years we did texas
oklahoma arkansas kentucky tennessee
and then there's obviously a bunch of
cyclical up and downs in in the oil and
gas industry as i'm sure you've heard
but
specific to with what we were doing
on the capital raising side right we
were dealing with not only accredited
investors but financial institutions who
would then fund these drilling
expeditions
um 2008 happened and with the housing
market crashing and then the financial
market crashing um i remember and this
was me being super super naive at a
young age was was telling myself that it
probably wasn't going to affect us as
much as it's affecting other people
right because we're drilling for oil or
gas it's either there or it's not there
um you know and it's a safer place i
guess you could say with the certainty
and predictability that shale plays had
for for people to put their money right
but again not knowing and being really
naive about the situation was
everybody was holding on to their money
nobody wanted to release it at that at
that point in time so um i just recently
got married we had our we had our
daughter right that we were talking
about and
uh
my wife was just saying hey we can't
deal with these ups and downs anymore
right we need something a little bit
more level which which i i agreed with
and
being on the investment side one of the
key questions we used to always get was
what do you guys have in renewables nice
right and so
my job at the time
being in in oil and gas was
well
you don't want to do renewables right uh
we're dealing with fossil fuels and
things of that nature and it was it was
more at the infancy stages on the
renewable sector where not a lot of
people knew what was going on anyways
but it it helped open my mind and then
if you couple that with
everything about the oil and gas
industry and and the pollutants and the
gases and everything else that it's
releasing into the environment um
i knew from more of a morality
perspective and an ethical standard is
that
there's got to be some better ways to
approach this whole energy thing right
and how can we do that and how can we
accomplish it and how can we at least
play a small part in that transition
so being here in the dallas-fort worth
area
again you know a mecca for for the oil
and gas industry here in texas is
there weren't a bunch of companies that
were doing renewable or solar or wind or
anything of that nature
but i was i was lucky enough through a
lot of due diligences that i had found a
local company that was dealing with the
residential market and um i've been in
sales since i was 16 17 years old so i
felt you know if anything i can kind of
go back and rely on
sales skills and and see what i can do
there and so i got connected uh and i
got hired on as a sales professional and
what we would do is we would go into
people's homes and show them ways that
they're able to reduce the consumption
in their house but also how they're able
to tackle
uh an offset through solar panels right
and installing solar on top of their
home instead of gaining all their
electricity from the utility grid yep
and uh
and in doing that right and again going
back to my whole entrepreneurial spirit
is is there there's i'm always trying to
find a better way to do things right and
sometimes there aren't sometimes there
aren't um but in this type of a
situation that i was in uh the company
that i was with kind of had a all-in-one
package right regardless of what your
situation was you're getting this this
this and that
right and i had to approach upper
management with hey how how about we
come in and we actually customize this
to the homeowner
because
i'm married i have four kids right uh
actually my next door neighbor who is
single lives in the same size home that
i'm in right
however
our living habits are different you know
he's gone at work all throughout the day
hardly ever using electricity
my wife is at home we have one child
that's being homeschooled you know the
other the other two are
are excuse me the two are in school and
then one's in a day care
so we're using a lot more electricity
throughout the day right above and
beyond that my comfort levels in my home
might be different than my neighbors so
every living situation was going to be a
little bit different so how can we
tailor make all of that to the
homeowner's specific needs
and they felt it would be too trying to
actually do that so i said you know what
i'm
i can i can i can do this right yeah so
i had i left there um and i started a
company um with two two friends of mine
um one that had a construction
background one that had a finance
background as well
and it was a perfect mesh and we created
a company called circle solar that we
founded in in 2014
and that was giving this is my first
entree into what a true holistic
approach looks like yep right
so we went in to we would train all of
our sales reps to go in and not actually
give a very good audit that meant you're
going in to their attic you're seeing
what type of insulation levels that they
have out there right we're taking
thermal temperatures of the home
we would do everything from
re-insulate their attic but we would
also do barrier type products a radiant
barrier that would go on on the rafters
of a roof to create a more suitable
environment inside the attic space
not only for the home and
heat penetration into the house but also
think about hvac equipment that is
actually sitting up there in a not so
great environment right you have an ac
system trying to produce out you know 50
degrees 60 degree air into your home
however your ducks in the ac system is
sitting in an attic that's 140 degrees
right kind of counterproductive if you
will
so
um
we did all that we brought in the
holistic approach uh even through water
heating solution hvac systems we did
high high efficiency systems that were
not your typical 14 16 here builder
grade models but we were doing 20 plus
year systems in homes where we could see
a reduction just on that alone of
between 25 30 percent of consumption um
led lighting and all that other good
stuff so we did that and uh we we grew
pr pretty rapidly
that's where the two entrepreneur awards
came from uh circleof was actually
uh
a top energy company in 2019 as well
through the american business awards
and um in a three-year period we had a
growth rate of over 2200 percent we were
featured on inc magazines fastest uh
growing companies in the us ranked 176.
and with all this came some notoriety
but also some interest from from private
equity firms and investment groups so we
actually ended up exiting that company
in july last year
but throughout this process on the
residential side is you know i thought
well this is scalable and not only is it
scalable in the residential market to
take it nationwide but think about
businesses right and the cni industry
and how many businesses are actually
losing energy that could otherwise be
rerouted and reused within their
facility but also think about
how they're getting charged for
electricity right and
from a business's perspective finances
are are key right it's a number one
driver while they'll make a decision on
on making an investment whether it's
solar or a new piece of equipment that's
going to make their their their facility
run more efficiently so
it's like how can we transition this to
the cni sector so we started doing that
and this was prior to us exiting we
started doing that about
in 2018 2019 and we started to get good
reception throughout the dfw market and
we
actually started to get a really good
reputation as well and then that kind of
grew nationwide and so
that's how we actually transition circle
solar to cls sustainable as a spin-off
and here we are today with cls
sustainable and we're a nationwide
developer epc
cls our our initiative when we first set
out was to only handle the epc
perspective which was the engineering
the procurement the construction
and one of the things that we were
finding
as doing epc work for for other
developers where a lot of developers
weren't developing the project correctly
right so they would lean on us for a lot
more of the development side of the work
so we actually took more of that on and
now we actually grew into more of a of a
development firm and an epc firm kind of
combined but again it kind of goes with
our whole mantra of bringing that
holistic approach and so it was one of
those other things of how can we better
service our customers and our clients
and it's the more stuff that we can
bring in house that we can eliminate
you know
broker fees or third-party fees or
things of that nature well
it not only benefits us as an
organization but it also benefits the
end user right because now you're
getting
same product that's going to be superior
in service but you're getting it at a
lesser rate so it's kind of a
win-win-win situation there yeah
so cool
yeah so i get long-winded man i love the
trajectory i love the history i love how
when you're sharing like some of these
first knocks from the investors
that were approaching the oil and
natural gas side of things where well
what do you guys have in renewables yeah
right that's so good like because that
those knocks are like the opening of the
mine to new possibilities for sure
um
and also even like your wife saying like
let's have something more stable yeah
for our kids right that was another like
a little knock on the right
um
and i love the when when you when you
began getting involved in residential
solar
i like how you also felt like a knock to
a next level which was well how do we
personalize this yes
tailor it to each home as it as the
needs of that home ask
and that's another great one and then
finding all the little
um optimizations and efficiency um so
like the sales would go in and do the
audit and the audit would cover the
areas
where like you said you wouldn't be
trying to blow 60 50 60 degree
fahrenheit cool air in
to a home where the hvac
uh
area would be true we would be trying to
traverse a 140 fahrenheit battery zone
so
uh all of that is a
it's like
the nuggets right on the trail yeah and
and then the entrepreneurial spirit
kicking in and like and um
and like really wanting to explore what
renewables and next-gen energy
technologies were
and
um and then even making an exit like
making an exit into cni
and
um and just seeing like well
and it's good being rewarded also with
awards because and like getting more
private equity interest and things like
that because those are also signs along
the way that damn things are going well
yeah and there's actually a lot of like
big money interested in
um the transition
not just making money but also like
there are esgs and sdgs and these like
initiatives that um money is now more
often needing to follow
um for a sustainable prosperous abundant
planet and future for generations to
come yeah
there are several indigenous tribes that
follow like a seventh generation
principle
where they don't make action unless they
know seven generations down the line is
going to be beneficial oh well and so
this is what clean energy technologies
are about yeah um so it's really
thinking multi-generationally
um so i love also how you were sharing
like there's so many different aspects
to um the integr to the
to the epc
of uh the cni and i would like to maybe
uh have you explain more about
what is it like having a cni project and
having cls fulfill that demand
so
having having a cni project and kind of
going back to what you're talking about
with esg right we're we're seeing that
mandate a whole lot more nowadays than
what we were seeing even two years ago
and
having a cni project that is looking
into renewables whether it's a mandate
or not because we've dealt with some
organizations some high-level
organizations where
they're saying that we're getting
mandates from a board of directors or
from investors or from vendors that
we're working with
that
we have to meet these certain standards
by let's say 2025 or 2030 right so we
want to be proactive and start getting
into it now and we understand that focus
but still at the end of the day
unfortunately it's more financial driven
than anything else right because again a
lot of these organizations they're
they're your fortune 100 or 500 a lot of
them are publicly traded where
they have a fiduciary responsibility to
an investment group as well
right that they have to make those types
of wise decisions but from our
perspective
uh again taking that and and giving
the off take or giving a giving a
customer these solutions is we take
everything from
the initial concept right where we
intake a project and this means we're
collecting 12 months worth of electrical
data right usage consumption not only on
their electricity but also on the
natural gas side as well
so and who would be an average customer
just that's an example uh an average
customer
it's really spread all across i mean it
could be school districts right it could
be municipalities but it could also be a
factory it could be a collision care
center you know a good size one but i
would say our average is going to be
one that is consuming roughly or i
should for simplicity say have a spend
of anywhere between
ten to twenty thousand dollars a month
in utilities right cool now don't get me
wrong we also service your smaller cni
customers that are only spending you
know five thousand dollars a month and
your larger ones that are spending seven
figures a month on their utility spend
cool so
all across the board cool um average
though right there
but we we intake the project um first
thing we do is an early stage due
diligence and we want to make sure that
a from a design side the feasibility to
fit enough panels on top is going to
make a significant dent
in what their consumption is
we also want to make sure from a utility
perspective that there's no hiccups as
far as or hurdles i should say
when it comes to
interconnecting the system to the
utility
we also want to figure out what their
net metering policy is
and that plays a significant role which
a lot of developers don't really do
their due diligence on
as far as how they're treating any type
of excess generation that's being put
back into the power grid
excuse me some will give you know what
we call a one for one credit
others give what's called an avoided
cost which is more down to a wholesale
rate which means i might be buying
electricity from you at eight cents but
anything i send back into the power grid
is gonna
you're gonna credit me back at three and
a half let's say so there's that delta
that you're missing there so that goes
into the whole design side and how we're
designing and offsetting a system
but we go through that early stage we
run financials on it we figure out how
the customer is looking to procure it
whether it's through
any capital expenditures that they have
available for it
or any type of finance mechanisms that
we can put in place for them whether
through power purchase agreements energy
services agreements things of that
nature
and that plays a crucial part because
obviously we want it to be a win-win for
everybody more importantly so for the
client and we need to make sure that
we're making them cash flow positive
from day one right
but after all that's put together and we
packaged it up really nicely and we
present it and go through not only all
the financial benefits but you know from
a sustainability side and more
importantly from our side is what you're
actually impacting what you're
contributing back to the earth so
there's a really cool
a couple pages on our on our uh
presentations that we do that show how
many you know trees they're saving from
being cut down you know how many uh
miles of cars from gasoline-powered
vehicles that we're taking off the road
equivalent wise
that this solar system is going to
produce form
nice
so then
we have uh let's go through the example
so we have a school
muni factory what not these a bigger
community projects
that are
applying or they're like deciding to
want to explore working together with
cls
and then
is cls
mainly focusing on solar
not necessarily so no wind is still
chp which which energy technologies do
you see so wind onsite for distributed
generation on the cni side is not really
that prevalent okay right um you're
gonna see a win more on the on the
utility set utility side um we're
looking at solar but we're also looking
at other types of generation systems
right so if uh like grocery chain for
instance right who's has a bunch of
chillers and coolers and everything
throughout their facility uh that every
time they're kicking on and off there's
big draws big amperage that's being
pulled and so when they're doing that
most utilities are going to charge like
kind of like a time of use or a demand
fee right depending upon what time of
day and what that cost is so a lot of
times when we're investigating a utility
bill we can find that those demand
charges are sometimes 40 to 50 percent
of what their overall bill is so solar
is only going to positively affect more
the supply side
but we have some other generation types
whether it's it's energy storage battery
energy storage or in situations like a
factory or a cold storage facility or
grocery chain
we can integrate combine heat and power
solutions which is chp solutions and
those are natural gas fire generation
that can offset and reduce that demand
but it also enables a facility to almost
almost island themselves and i'm sure
you've heard the term micro grid right
so you can kind of somewhat create a
micro grid for your facility where now
solar
chp energy storage is your main source
of of energy so good and you're only
using the utility as a backup backup
yeah
great so that's the vision of working
with cls yep cool yeah
we don't want to be just one-sided and
look at look at solar
by itself unless we do our investigation
and we find out right that demand costs
are too low where chp won't make too
much of a difference right uh but here
in texas and i'm sure as people have
heard around the country back in
february of last year you know the the
the power grid went down um there were a
ton of people who who were without
electricity for for quite some time
unfortunately at uh
at the time we still had circle l but we
had one of our workers who uh lost
electricity for him and his family and
ended up putting a generator in his home
and uh ended up passing in the night
because of all the carbon monoxide that
was that was
being released into his house just to
keep his family warm
so uh but that those types of scenarios
and situations
um
we can't because of the way the
infrastructure is it's so old it's
outdated that we can't be totally and
solely relied upon them right
this gives us an opportunity to kind of
take those matters into our own hands
yes produce electricity for ourselves
be able to back up
generation for ourselves almost island
ourselves be resilient yes but do it at
a cost that's less than what you're
actually paying your current utility
which is so win-win-win no-brainer for
sure love it so then
i love the conversation about the uh the
micro grid or like the islanding yeah
it's very interesting so
so what the
so what the cni existingly is paying in
its monthly utilities
will uh will decrease by
10 or something like that by this
transition to solar and chp or whatever
um
and they're no longer going to be paying
that amount correct because they're
actually then um that's the cost that
they're paying into the uh the principle
of or whatnot of the payment for the
next-gen technologies correct yeah
so then they're going to be the owners
also of the technologies after a period
of maybe 10 20 something years like that
correct yeah so in an outright purchase
they're an owner from day one they can
sign what's called an o m or operation
and maintenance agreement to have
someone like ourselves come in and just
keep up with the monitoring of the
system you know maintain the system
annually or every five years whatever
the case is
but if they were to opt for let's say a
ppa a power purchase agreement or an esa
which is an energy services agreement
where we would facilitate everything
facilitate the financing we could even
own and operate the system we maintain
it throughout that esa period and like
you were saying it could be
seven years it could be ten it could be
fifty it could be as long as 25 years if
they wanted it to be um
but it kind of makes it carefree from
them in that perspective but still even
at the end
they're still owning their own power
right they're generating it on site and
after that esa or ppa
period is up they fully take over that
system cool
and so then yeah this is so
i just it's it is also very relaxing
just hearing about it really
um
because i'm i'm just feeling that
there's so many industries um
that are looking for this
and now to have it packaged into a
solution that then makes it easily
accessible and frictionless as
frictionless as possible and to win for
them a win for you a win for the planet
um
is so so good though the only kind of
person that's not a win for is the old
infrastructures right and that's okay
because um
there's going to be plenty of
opportunity for them to sort of let go
of the old stuff and to get involved in
the new stuff for sure
um so
you know it just reminds me of
of uh
you know the ones that were screaming
for horses when cars were being invented
yeah so it's it's cool like we can let
go
of the old and yeah and usher in the new
yeah yeah
you always have that little
uncomfortable uncomfortable period right
where that transition is being made
and i feel like there was a great
analogy that you were saying with
between the horses and the cars and
we're seeing that now in the energy
industry between fossil fuels and
renewables and there does have to become
a period
where you do have to let go of those old
methodologies and and start to adapt the
new ones and especially when they usher
in independence and these microgrids
these
no-brainers of them not being reliant on
an externality
and paying more for that externality but
instead paying less and owning your own
uh renewable tech stack
so so brilliant this is my this is truly
my favorite part of this
um
this next-gen energy technologies
movement and especially
how
this is all um funneling into this like
home dao mechanism yeah um so let's
let's talk about that so so cls uh
coming on board as a developer in the
home dao ecosystem
um
so how did you guys get excited and
involved about this and what excites you
most about the mechanism itself yeah
well uh andy bittner with gce whom we've
worked with before in the past
um had approaches with this uh along
with another group that that we're all
involved with and at the beginning
because i don't have too much knowledge
uh about you know blockchains and taos
and things of that nature i didn't at
the time um it was a really really
interesting concept right and
it was almost one of those things where
it's like man this this sounds too good
to be true oh type deal
but as uh you know andy and some of our
colleagues started explaining a little
bit more and kind of just putting it
down on paper like this is what it what
it's all looking at
my partner kevin and i looked at each
other like man
we're either gonna
be involved in something that's really
really really ground breaking if we
decided to move forward with this and
and i don't even think ground breaking's
the right word i'm not even doing it
justice you know what this could be
um or
we're going to just kind of stick to our
own methodologies and and we're going to
miss out on something big
so it's like do we want to jump in and
take that risk and and we both had the
same response and it was absolutely 100
and so
we're really really excited that that
we've been asked to kind of join and
help and participate
i think what it means from us or from me
personally
is
having my background in the in the
financial industry and how everything is
just so regulated right
and
things can get at times political or
politically driven in the finance world
uh this kind of
decentralizes all of that right and and
now
uh with like smart contracts and
everything else it's like there's these
digital imprints that are already there
that are proof
there's no way around it everybody has
to be transparent right and i think that
word transparent is a is a great
buzzword nowadays but i think people are
over using it you know what i mean but
this is like the true spirit of
transparency yeah and uh and so
everybody who is involved from
investors to the developers to even the
end users they all have that same level
of transparency versus
we know things that you don't know and
we know things that you don't know right
so
that's probably one of the most exciting
things about it is that is that that
transparency is there for for all to see
not only
um
which used to be the
high-level investor groups knew
everything right and you knew a little
bit and they didn't know much um now
everybody's on the same playing field
yeah yeah
and another one
that um
that i got really excited about
was when when we were designing uh the
visual that we've had up in the
um the previous episode we did with andy
the first one
um
that
there's a
streamlining
of
um
the funding to the developers yeah for
epc yep and
uh do you talk also about like your
excitement about that oh yeah yeah that
that as far as the the back end and the
execution part that the funding aspect
is is something i'm super excited about
because now this allows
developers and epcs that are out there
who have been looking for funding or
looking for the right funding partners
in order to get projects done
this kind of streamlines that process
forum
it makes the process a lot easier for
an epc to bring a client
to the dao so cool yeah it is it is good
and and so the end user who we really
want to benefit from the system the most
both financially and environmentally
gets to accomplish that right as to
where today you know trying to find a
debt stack or or capital stack that's
going to finance one of these projects
and you're having to go through big
banks with big fees and big interests
and all that other stuff
everything kind of gets diluted before
it gets to the end whereas this process
kind of mitigates that yeah
so good uh and then
um
how about
um
how
are the like existing how will home dao
how will that help the sort of the
existing funnel or pipeline that is
besides like the streamlining of funding
and
um
i'm just envisioning all of these uh
prospective clients that are very
interested in what cls uh
can offer to them um and the home dow
sort of like facilitating like the
onboarding of this process with the
streamlining funds and stuff so you just
speak to that
yeah so
and and to be quite frank without know
having limited knowledge i guess on the
process from the dallas perspective
right now if we were to onboard a client
to go through a traditional methodology
of getting a power purchase agreement or
energy services agreement there's a
pretty long drawn out process that
that's in place right from
um
gaining any type of credentials that
they have when it comes to their credit
business credit sometimes personal
credit of the business owner
structuring a deal pro
properly but then there's also the fees
and everything else that are going to be
associated with that origination fees
and and so on and so forth so
uh and again it's a
it's it's the back end part of that that
i think the dao is going to eliminate
tremendously and make it so much simpler
and easier
for
again
all parties involved to go from point a
to point b in a shorter period of time
get there a lot quicker right and i
think what that means for a lot of the
epcs and developers that are out there
unless you're a large developer large
epc
who have either
a family office or a funding institution
that you've been working with for quite
some time it's a lot more difficult for
your your smaller your mid-sized ones to
cultivate and create those types of
relationships to then be able to offer
that
to the off taker right
more importantly too
which i feel and things that we've
talked about around this structure is
actually giving the opportunity for the
epc for the developer to actually
partake in the ownership aspect huge of
that facility exactly no financial
institutions right now allow for
developers or epcs to come in and
partake in that part that's cool yeah
cool
so then there's the inclusive
stakeholding of the epc in the
development process and there's the
facilitation of all those things that
you're listing as variables at the very
beginning to sort of uh
not need
in a sense a lot of that and or to
simplify it down to smart contracts for
sure in essence and then
to
um
and then to take sort of the power in a
sense away from the old um and bring it
to
the i love how you called it the micro
grid aspect um which is like the the
ownership is local yeah um and it's next
gen yep and um this is so so exciting
and um we we have had a shorter like
first episode we could say um with deke
um
but this is great to even have had the
first conversation about the history is
so crucial sort of all these little
nuggets on the way that got us to cls
and then what cls is and then also how
we'll be involved in home dial so it's a
good solid first episode and we'll uh
we'll be able to revisit this as we
continue um for sure blossoming this
ecosystem we'll be able to revisit for
continued um episodes and continued um
using this as like a magnet to like to
attract people from around the world to
get involved in this in this ecosystem
of next-gen technologies for energy
production and for
meeting the needs of people worldwide um
and then so much cool uh play is
unlocked through that oh absolutely 100
yeah we're
we're super excited about the
opportunity we're we're really excited
that that where we've been asked to be
involved in this and uh just can't can't
wait to see where it takes us all
yeah and the stories are so good of like
dkevin kevin's about to be the third
episode on the hotel podcast um
and like and just what you guys have
built out truly like thank you for
building this out for dedicating your
lives to building out the transition to
the next gen tech and uh and for joining
this mechanism
[Music]
bro
it is it is thanks for having us we
appreciate it thank you for coming on
thanks to the audience for tuning in we
hugely appreciate you all
we would love for you guys to check out
the links in the bio below you can find
the cls sustainable.com link down there
you can find out deek's linkedin profile
connect with him there
you can also find the home dao links
below thehomedow.com
you can also find the the twitter down
there the youtube down there also the
discord down there if you'd like to join
and share this video if you feel like
this brought a new perspective for you
and you feel like sharing it with other
people do so that's probably the most
powerful thing you can do share the
actual video itself
and you can also like the video to help
boost it in the algorithm and also
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet
thanks everyone we love you so much
thanks for tuning in
much love
peace